flippy from
indiana flippy from indiana please
unmute you are on the air my friend
hi can you hear me yes i can hey david
it's me
um i just was wondering if you've ever
reconsidered making it only fans
sorry if i if i've done making an
omelette what no no making it only fans
uh you know
uh burning season is over and it's time
for you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
floppy dukes flippy floppy
five and a quarter
and i was called by the biggest dumps
they call them dumps
big massive dumps
big massive dumpster
big massive dumb
[Music]
huge dumps in michigan
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
let's please continue on person woman
man camera tv all the networks
all the networks person woman
man camera tv
that's amazing how did you do that
[Music]
i do it because i have like a good
memory because i'm
cognitively there
all right welcome everybody um so many
questions so little time and so much
going on we're standing by for
joe biden now with the coronavirus
stimulus package signed
into law we are going to hear from joe
biden about its implementations when
might you get something
from the bill we are going to hear
important news about that from joe biden
momentarily
we are also monitoring this should be
funny republican lawmakers
are i guess about to visit the u.s
mexico border and i can only
imagine it will be uh the depths of
republican propaganda so we're keeping
an eye
on that as well and we also have the
last few minutes of the gensake
press briefing so let's just listen into
this and then i've got a whole bunch of
other things i have no
unban requests for people already
demanding them
no unban requests right now let's listen
to work with the quad members to provide
to
a range of countries and regions and we
are so certainly open to discussing and
considering um you know when we can
provide additional supply but i don't
have anything to preview for you predict
in terms of the timeline
we're going to have to just go on
because we or otherwise we're not going
to get to everybody go ahead
um so a new poll from npr and marist
said that nearly half of republican men
won't get the vaccine whether it's
available to them and and i know
that last week you said that the
democratic administration might not
always be the best messenger to
communicate to
everyone kind of the importance and the
benefits of getting the vaccine
and so i just wanted to ask if the white
house is making plans to try to boost
republican
receptivity to the vaccine and can you
share what any of those ideas are
sure um first the president's goal is to
vaccinate all americans not just those
who voted
for him right now the phase we're in is
that demand for the vaccine still
outstrips supply
we won't be in that phase forever but
right now the big
issue is access and people wanting to
have access to the vaccine
and so we're focusing on how to make it
as convenient and accessible for
americans
as possible and i talked about this very
briefly last week uh but
uh we know we need to meet everyone
where they are and that includes uh
conservatives
um uh and ensure there are trusted
messengers who
lead the way in those engagements 81
percent of republicans said they would
trust their own doctor or health care
provider in some polling that came out
this weekend
to provide reliable information about a
covid 19
vaccine you know this is consistent with
what i was conveying last week and some
of the data that we've seen internally
about how
yes there are a number of prominent
officials out there who
if they were more vocal about getting
the vaccine we'd certainly support that
but
also doctors and local health providers
are
we see poll after poll are are the most
one of the most
trusted authorities in communities
regardless of people's political
affiliation
as our religious leaders um and uh local
uh leaders uh as well so we are very
mindful of that and thinking of ways to
support and power you know help fund
those what about just let them think of
it as the trump vaccine if it'll get
them to get vaccinated
real stakeholders department partner
with them in boosting vaccine confidence
but i also have a couple of examples
that i found interesting hopefully you
do as well
uh you know we are focused on earned
media and establishing partnerships with
trusted messengers right now
we will quickly move to a public a big
public campaign which will be run out of
hhs there's even some
funding in the american rescue plan for
that that will be a part of it that
hopefully will have more to say on in a
couple of weeks but
uh some a couple of examples tomorrow dr
fauci and dr collins
will be hosting an event with
evangelical leaders to discuss the
vaccine and how we can partner
with them uh dr collins uh has appeared
on the 700 club
we also have done of course a range of
engagements with different
communities seven hundred club is the
credentials wacky but again we're trying
to convince trumpists here
did an interview with gloria stefan
which now i want to go find and watch
myself as i'm sure many of you do
uh so we are trying to be creative on
earned media to
meet people where they are but we're
also mindful of
empowering supporting um local
trusted voices because we've seen that
in poll after poll to be an effective
way of reaching a range of communities
dr fauci said recently that former
president trump getting involved in this
big game changer for
uh encouraging republicans to take the
vaccine did you guys agree and does
president biden want to see
trump get involved in this messaging
well that's not my phone vibrating guys
that's somewhere in the room
wanted to be more vocal about the safety
and efficacy of the campaign
of the of the vaccine certainly we
support that
uh but uh also i think what's important
to note is that as i noted
81 percent of republicans said they
would trust their own doctor or health
care provider and that's an important
place to invest
every other living former president or
most of them if not all of them
has participated in public campaigns
they did not need an engraved invitation
to do so
so right why does biden need to say
trump should do something trump should
just do it if he thinks
it's what's right reach out to ensure
that people of a range of political
support and backing uh know the vaccine
is safe and
and safe and effective go ahead and
thanks so much first question is back on
the border there were lawyers who
interviewed some children that were in
facilities the children described
sleeping on the floor being hungry not
being dumping the sun for days
how is that acceptable for the body
administration to keep children
in those sorts of conditions given the
fact that she said you you were an
administration that's going to be more
humane than
the previous pair well these let me
first say this is um
heartbreaking uh it's a very emotional
issue for a lot of people
and it's very difficult and challenging
and obviously
these tbp facilities are not made for
kids
so one of the reasons or a driving
reason why
the president has pushed to take all of
the actions that i
outlined earlier when phil asked the
question is because we want to expedite
getting these kids out of these cbp
facilities
as quickly as possible and that's our
goal and our objective and into shelters
as quickly as possible then into
sponsored homes while their cases are
being
considered and adjudicated uh we are
trying to work through what was a
dismantled and unprepared system
because of the the f the role of the
last administration
that's very true this is not our main
thing today that that phone buzzing is
is insufferable so we're going to mute
out this is almost over and then joe
biden will speak
momentarily and then also republicans
are doing a propaganda event
at the border so we'll keep the video up
but i
i do want to make sure to allow time for
everything that i planned for
um as there are so many different things
i plan for let me start with a couple of
super chats dara 10 says has the trump
loss hit the david pakman show worse
than expected
no i mean listen everybody know the
election years are always the best in a
four-year cycle
and then usually the year after
particularly q1
january february march there's a decline
we didn't see a decline we just saw
slower growth so we're really we're
really doing okay as far as
overall audience goes where we've been
hit
really hard is that in february we had
the worst month from the standpoint of
new members
in over a year and it's sort of like a
two there were two reasons why one
continued economic pressure from the
virus
and then on the other hand february is
only 28 days sometimes 29
28 this time and so fewer days for
people to sign up and the way the
weekends lined up it just
it was it was just a it was a perfect
storm to quote myself from a documentary
film i was recently interviewed in
and so so memberships were disaster in
february but we're still adding about a
thousand youtube subscribers a day
at one point we were adding four
thousand a day and i know that i've seen
some of our colleagues are adding zero
like
some of our colleagues have gone to zero
growth we're still adding about a
thousand
um subscribers a day on youtube and
twitch is doing all right i mean we i
think we hit about 2 600 subscribers
um and then now we're down to 14 but
still about half the month to go so it's
about what we expected
and it's a reorganization time is all it
is uh we still
uh on on the daily are getting about a
million youtube views a day
which is where i want to be like it
would be great to get the 2.2 million
that we got at one point but a million
views a day
is still beautiful um so
you know it's it's all part of the plan
january
although it was down from december was
still our best january ever i think
that's an important thing to keep in
mind february different story
different story borrow rudd says i got
my fourteen hundred dollars yesterday
so this is what i owe you if i had
become a website member
without using the borderline illegal
discount code thanks for keeping me sane
we did finally hear cyrus vance's team
reached out
and said you know what david the coupon
codes
they're not borderline illegal they're
illegal
and we're coming for you so uh people
better know
that uh that that those are soon
soon to be prosecutions but they're
gonna grandfather everybody in is the
good news
for people saying i don't stream enough
my main thing isn't streaming
streaming is like an aside streaming
kind of started because of the pandemic
where i you know i'm just
not doing anything but our main things
are the podcast the tv radio show the
youtube clips
uh facebook clips igtv um
and the the streaming is really really
an aside
super evil monkey says can you comment
on the accusations by rm
brown about your alleged blue chew
addiction
many flushing toilets i have never tried
blue chew and i don't claim to in
the we have bluetooth as an advertiser i
never claim
uh that i've used the product merely
that there should be no stigma
around using such a product that's
that's my claim
and uh i am sticking with it a few other
people oh i do want to thank some people
mario ev
has subscribed with prime do you grok
has subscribed and says
first it's a hoax now it's daddy trump
that saved all of us but they won't take
the vaccine how do these people get
through the day
ignorance and cognitive dissonance
basically
that's do you grok thanks to the nate
dog for the sub
flea girl megan solo
taco light as well as just call me
snips that is six people
who have signed up via twitch and we
absolutely love that steven says i just
received the word the u.s
attorney for the district of
massachusetts is investigating your
coupon codes
use it while you still can better 21.
yeah that's that's
uh that's more or less the legal notice
that i got
uh let's see a couple of mimetic
elements for you guys as this press
briefing wraps up we're still standing
by for republicans on the border
joe biden is going to be speaking soon
about people getting stimulus money
um somebody sent this to me through the
through the subreddit
this i get i don't know who this is this
is a tick tock memer
doing a parody if i understand correctly
this is of
of my live call segments let's listen to
this together
well the david pakman show uh
is funded primarily by membership that's
true
go to joinpacman.com all true
coupon code still works
phone fridays suck because
my callers suck let's actually go now
to the phones let's speak first to uh
pedro from colombia
pedro como estas now
my spanish is better than this guys i
hope people get me give me credit for
that i'm guessing this is not a native
speaker of spanish we can forgive that
they're bachmann i got covered
uh i'm not feeling too good
pedro what part of colombia
are you from de donde eres
now of course i'm argentinian so i say
i don't say that onder so now it's now
it's not so good
pacman i forgot you forgot okay
muchas gracias pedro let's go
uh next to uh james
all right so there it is that's satire
of friday
phone calls that's not bad and then
here's another one i don't know who this
is it was sent to me it's someone named
hoss bossman
with 300 subscribers on youtube and they
did
i guess they like me this question who
is your favorite
lib slash normie political commentator
normie pacman out for mine he's like a
social democrat
not as far left as i am i guess but he's
real smart
and obviously cares deeply about
presenting his views in a rigorous and
like transparent way
and he's just freaking adorable i love
him i'm posting this video to my channel
right now even though i'm very sweaty
and
fancy is also kind of hot but i'm
putting this video up not to deliver my
hot takes on
like his views on american imperialism
i've definitely heard him say some stuff
i disagree with
shots fired across the bow i've always
thought david pagman approached
commentating on politics and in like
admirable way and i truly believe
like you're getting an honest look at
the news and whatnot from his
perspective when you watch
the show anyway his earnestness and
awkwardness are so
endearing and i'm begging you to please
go down to the description of this video
after it's finished
and watch his recent video on tucker
carlson
please it's called tucker carlson says
listening to doctors is gay
so tucker doesn't actually say that but
david pakman is so hilarious and
endearing this video you have to watch
it
it's like he's trying to approach the
content of what tucker's saying in good
faith like bending over backward to try
and do so in fact and it only serves to
further highlight how
like stupid what tucker is saying i
don't know i just love this so much
i've watched it like a dozen times i
start cracking up
right around the time he says
troglodytic did you see how tucker did
that
he doesn't use the word gay and he
doesn't
say it's his idea but then he says
it's sort of like listening to dr fauci
the chinese doctor saying we've become
delicate timid and effeminate that's
sort of like when we listen to dr fauci
when dr fauci as a doctor explains how
viruses work and suggests what people
should do
if you listen to that it's sort of gay
that's that's the code language
that is being used here this is just red
meat for the right
it's another version of the real men
don't go to the doctor
type of sort of troglodytic thinking
and then it just snowballs from there
and i'm in tears
what's so funny about this please tell
me what you think in the comments i
can't quite put my finger on
yeah what's a tiny bit odd about david
pakman and like i said i love him
you owe it to yourself to watch and or
listen to him subscribe to him he's very
good
his is one of the more hilarious
interactions i've seen between jessie
lee peterson
and a lefty person like testing the
waters with that
person peterson is insane if you've
never seen him
beta and david pakman very much tries to
take him seriously
and the result is just like beautiful
and awesome see what's funny is people
don't get that i'm only pretending to
to take jessie lee peterson seriously
like that's the joke the joke is
i pretend to be taking him seriously but
in reality i'm taking nothing seriously
at all
and i think sometimes it gets
misunderstood as like i actually i have
no idea that it's not going to be a
serious interview
of course i do i've just decided that
rather than trying to match him
i'll just pretend like i'm taking it
seriously it's a stylistic decision
it's meta meta beautifully said
in the uh in the chat i want to say
thanks to bw
rock for signing up at joinpakman.com
and mark barash you guys are new members
seven and eight today appreciate that
also want to say thanks to blaze king
for the twitch sub
um oh just blaze king okay i thought i
had somebody else to thank
just just blaze king and
the coupon code is working absolutely
okay ferret queen wants to know
have you noticed a slight disrespectful
tone towards jen saki by the press i
feel like they're either bullying the
new kid or maybe they don't like seeing
a woman with knowledge and confidence
no no what i'm seeing is sometimes
questions meant to be tough
are just stupid and that's it like they
they're trying to ask tough questions
but they're really just stupid questions
and uh i don't know that's that's about
it
okay let's see uh i do have one unban
request to adjudicate
we are calling to order this uh live
stream as a court of unbanned requests
if you've been banned on twitch
you can submit an unban request a user
named lavish leviathan
sent asc to art of a phallus
they were banned and then asked why was
i banned
this unbanned request is going to be
hereby denied
and it has been made a permanent
and that is an easy one that is a very
very easy one
um and that's it we have cleared we have
cleared the role the
the um q so to speak
of unban requests so we've gotten that
out of the way uh real quick we'll we'll
do this again and
recently it's gone to know i have new
troy york voicemails
if you want me to play them i will and
if you don't i won't i'm gonna paste
a link to a straw poll on twitch which
i've just done
i'm going to paste a link to the same
straw poll
on youtube if you're watching on
facebook come over to twitch or youtube
and you'll find how to vote um
originally people wanted troy york
voicemails
more recently a people have not these
have gone negative and we've now
rejected troy york voicemails two times
i do have a few
where he's calling in with new
characters i don't even know what points
he's trying to make i didn't even listen
to them
uh but if you want to weigh in now is
the time to do it
and soon we should start seeing the
votes tally it takes some time
um steven says it's frustrating when
people don't get your dry wit
i know stephen i know we just have to
live with it
andrew says hello are you the same guy
from the world famous award-winning
bonus show cheers from russia yes that's
me
that's absolutely me i'm the guy from
that thing yep
totally so that's that also want to say
thanks to wooly bear
deretend technicallys for signing up via
twitch that's
three putting us at 12. early votes
all on no for troy york voicemails
i've pasted the link a bunch of times
i'll paste it again
in twitch chat and then i'm pasting it
again
in youtube chat for some reason this
the straw poll website works really
weirdly lately where it'll first just
like put up a bunch of votes
on either yes or no and then eventually
there it is
oh the yes is slightly ahead it looks
like there's pushback last time
no one and it looks like maybe now
people are wanting uh
people are wanting the troy york
voicemail so with 292 votes just
slightly things are on yes we'll give it
a little bit more time
and see what happens with that um
people can certainly keep voting in the
meantime oh i did want to do covet
updates
the numbers continue to improve you can
keep voting even though it's off screen
we had another decline yesterday
and we now are seeing it's it's leveling
out but numbers are still going down we
had this big peak about 255
000 cases a day we got down to 69 and
had a spike
and then now we're down to 54 000 cases
a day
more acutely declining are deaths which
is very important
um as as folks more at risk get
vaccinated we would expect deaths to
decline they
peaked at about 34 40 deaths per day
came down to about 2 000 and popped a
little bit
and then now we're down to about 1 300
still tragic
still tragic but the numbers are going
in the right direction and we had
some massive dumps of vaccine data on
saturday
4.5 million people didn't really get
vaccinated on saturday but
the methodology was slightly changed
which explains why the number was so
high saturday
but then so much lower on sunday but the
point is 2.39
million doses per day biden promised 1
million
we got to 2 million we're on our way to
2.5 and hopefully three
so that's that's really really good
stuff and that's going well
all right troy york voicemails it is
really down to the wire
51 to 49 people want to hear the troy
york voicemails
now the no's have taken over people
saying
no troy york voicemails we may not get
them
thanks to matro b for the 10 month
subscription on twitch
also thanks to bobofetra who subbed and
says thanks for all you do david i get
excited when i see you're going live
keep up the massive dumps of great
content
don vagenous has subscribed
that is 3 12 plus 3 2 plus 3 is
5 and then 1 is 15
so that's looking very very good also
thanks to dalton haskin
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
dalton
thank you you're a great american my
friend as sean hannity would say
i think i'm ready to call it on the troy
york voicemails unless there's like a
big
big drop in now of votes i think very
slightly
the audience has voted no no on
voicemails
52-48 let's maybe give it one more
update we're at about
500 votes cast so far
uh yeah refreshing doesn't do anything
it just like it
it's just slow i don't know why
497
uh yeah i'm not gonna paste the link
anymore and by the way
if you say in the chat yes or no it
doesn't count
only voting counts i feel like obama
don't tweet
vote sending me chats
come on guys okay noah is winning
noah's winning is the point this might
be it
i don't know why it's not updating it's
just it's very very strange
i guess i'm just calling it
yeah okay all right that's it we're done
it is a no
it is a no no no on uh troy york
voicemails once again two in a row we
may be done with troy york voicemails
forever
we may never see troy york voicemails
again the way uh
the way things are going let's take a
look at a clip
from newsmax this is pretty funny stuff
they had on
eric balling who like used to be on fox
i don't know if he still is
and he is warning us with a very
powerful warning
socialism maybe even communism might be
coming let's take a listen to this
heather this is absolutely driving us
directly towards
socialism maybe even communism 1.9
trillion dollars
you know we have a 28 trillion dollar
deficit as it is
and it's expanding faster than it ever
has president nope it expanded faster
under trump
obama doubled the deficit from 10
trillion to 20 trillion
no so no he's talking about
the debt oh my god i can't even believe
we're doing this guys this is an adult
this is an adult
trump took over and added 8 trillion
onto it what biden is about to do
in addition to all the extra spending
that we already have in place
biden is going to add another probably
20
25 trillion dollars to now he said that
the
covet stimulus bill gets us close to
socialism
or maybe even communism now
socialism is a political and economic
theory
which advocates that the means of
production distribution and exchange
should be owned or regulated by the
community so for example if you say
private business instead of having an
owner
it's owned by all of the employees by
law
okay if a business has 20 employees
there's 20 owners that's
socialism there's nothing in covet
stimulus
that affects the ownership of business
of means of production distribution or
exchange
nothing okay communism
is a political theory advocating class
war leading to a society where all
property is publicly owned and each
person
works and is paid according to their
abilities and needs typically because
the government
is the sole employer the government
decides even sometimes who works where
owns the businesses decides who makes
what amounts of money
there is nothing in the 1.9 trillion
dollar stimulus bill
that is anything at all like communism
there's no socialism in the bill
and there's no communism in the bill but
that doesn't matter to eric balling
who says this is scary the trump
two stimulus packages those weren't
socialism or communism
for right wingers the biden stimulus is
now socialism or communism
the deficit in in the first four maybe
if he
gets re-elected eight years we're headed
towards absolute insolvency now remember
who owns now they've been saying this
for 40 years they've been saying for 40
years
that inflation is going to explode
it hasn't inflation has been very well
controlled in the united states it
remained very well controlled
during the 2009 tarp it remained
controlled throughout all of these
different things
it's the same it just never happens most
of our debt
china owns most of our debt they hold
our debt if interest rates go up
we're absolutely screwed on a perce
you should look at how much debt japan
owns in fact look at this
uh who owns u.s debt by country
check this out uh
where is the by country part of it
public debt
looking for the list of countries here
yeah look
japan is a bigger holder of public debt
why do they talk about china they talk
about
china because it's part of the political
story they like to tell and in
particular
when a democrat is president they like
to talk about the cozy relationship
between the democrat and china
so they talk about chinese debt japan
owns more debt
than china does of the united states
they never talk about it
they just never talk about it um every
single one of these statements
is exactly what we would expect from
someone
weaponized and disinformed like eric
balling
right now we're gonna service that debt
to the tune of a trillion dollars these
numbers sound
massive and they are if interest rates
go up it could be two trillion dollars
just
to pay the interest on the debt not
actually pay down the debt
yeah i mean it's like i'm that's enough
that's enough it's like dude learn about
modern monetary theory learn about
something
let's now go to a republican propaganda
event on the u.s mexico border as we
wait for joe biden and they're doing it
now masterfully
they're doing it because president biden
rolled back a lot of the orders of the
previous administration that were
working
one of the perhaps most reprehensible
things i've heard in a long time
is nancy pelosi in summon administration
saying
that this is caused by uh pent up demand
from the previous administration oh my
goodness pent up demand for
crime crossing the border legally is
illegal
and so we shouldn't accommodate that
pent-up demand they seem to be signaling
that we should
and here's what's happening uh there's
no question this trip has confirmed it
for me
there is indeed disorder at the border
by executive order
no question about it we went first to a
detention facility
48 million dollars to build they're
spending tens of thousands of dollars a
day
who built it this surge they're spending
tens of thousand dollars more a day
to close them to transfer them all this
money is taken being taken apart
away from things we're doing here in the
country why wasn't he saying this when
trump was president
bad from a from a financial standpoint
for border patrol that as kevin alluded
to
they're taking money from the future
payments down the road
later in the year of border patrol
salaries and border patrol pensions
just to try and pay for the surge don't
they ever
you know you guys know how for example
in theory
the police doesn't want people to speed
because it's unsafe
but the police depends on people
speeding
to give them speeding tickets to remain
funded
and if really there was no speeding we
would actually have an immediate funding
problem for police
you could probably fire police officers
so like in reality if no one's sped
it'd be bad for police they never
account for the idea that
if the wall really was as effective as
trump claimed it would be
if he built it and of course he didn't
and you know all the stuff
you'd you'd be laying off border patrol
right because
they'd have nothing to do because the
wall would be so effective
they never will address this issue and
it's always just couched as
uh we we needed we did the border patrol
is going to have a problem here because
you it's it's
stunning how there's this narrative just
persists as politically convenient based
on who's in office include these kids
coming across
and by the way when kids come across if
you don't think the drug traffickers are
doing it
think again most men have a piece of
tape across their shirt with
instructions on who they are
where they're going and what information
they get and what they need to do
so that's very organized and they're
paying a lot of money per child to get
them across
right that's all that's not new that's
always been the case me as a homeland
security
ranking member people they've caught in
the last few days
over there in sector three or monument
three have been under uh terror watch
list
individuals that they have on the watch
list for terrorism are now starting to
exploit the southern border terrorism we
need to wake up
we need to understand listen mr
president biden you're an okay guy
why don't you just admit you made a
mistake with this policy and go back to
the way it was and keep america safe for
all of us
and and use that money that we're
wasting down here
on our american citizens the door should
not be open
and we should have immigration why
didn't he suggest this to trump
tony gonzalez from homeland security
committee up here tony's from texas
and he's going to talk to you more thank
you very much
so this is a waste of our time i don't
think we're going to listen to very much
more of it we are waiting for joe
biden's remarks about implementation of
stimulus money when will you get the
money how is it all going to
work we will keep an eye on this i guess
even though it's really quite a
quite a waste of time a few things via
super chat coming in
are you a good drummer will we ever get
a demonstration yeah maybe i'm all right
i'm all right joe bom syria without
congress approval equals impeachment all
right
you could advocate for that joshua
ellsworth says trump lost because his
legs are virtually hairless
i don't know if people care about that
daraten says new dr
seuss disorder disorder by executive
order yeah
that would be a good that'd be a nice
book that would be a good dr
seuss story thanks to the young greg for
subscribing via twitch
also want to say thanks to jennifer for
subscribing via twitch
whether boxer has subscribed silent one
has subscribed
skip dog has subscribed that is
five five plus six is
eleven carry the one is twenty one
appreciate that very much oh sorry and
also
thanks to chuck make it
for subscribing via twitch number 22
uh yes the coupon code is working on the
website i would be up for doing a new
coupon code should we do a new coupon
code just for fun
um we haven't had a new coupon code for
a while and i'm really able to do uh
anything as far as a coupon code goes
kate smith wants to know how are the
zooks coming along i have not planted
any zucchini yet or anything like that
i'm uh i'm standing by on that
let's see here new coupon code we will
make it
coupons we're gonna make this massive
this is going to be a massive coupon
code let me just see here
hold on that's not working
there we go all right new code where on
earth is the new code button
i don't even know how my own website
works this is crazy
add new oh there it is yeah this will be
a stream only coupon code
let's see what people are suggesting
coupon code big boy
coupon code adorable massive cuts
massive coup dump illegal coupon code
420. fresh
shart scam
dumps 21 steel 21
stimi zuk's
yeah i don't know it could really go
either way there's a lot of ones
hairless legs i don't think so
beta but beta misspelled
wow there's some pretty aggressive codes
here
tickle me that's not good
that's not good let's let's do um
how about immoral 21 i don't want people
to think that the coupon codes are
illegal but they're certainly immoral
and let's do a discount i'm going to
make this a big discount but i'm not
even going to tell people how big of a
discount it is
it's going to be a special number it'll
be a number that's meaningful to a lot
of people but i won't even say what it
is all right here we go i've got an idea
and we'll apply it to all memberships
and
publish this is a
coupon coup d'etat all right the code
is is it live hold on
the code is live and it is immoral 21
immoral 21 all one word all lowercase
it is not illegal but oh someone already
figured out it's 69
off okay man that happened quickly
immoral 21 is the coupon code thank you
everybody
very very exciting stuff we won't be
publishing that anywhere for liability
reasons obviously
okay jack lewis suggests the coupon code
stimulus chakaseki says great show
from saturday in baltimore with the mike
clark experience doing a herbie hancock
tribute on youtube
he wrote the amazing actual proof drum
beat all right very good
chakaseki david can you break down the
lindsey graham axios interview
i sort of feel like i've just missed the
opportunity like i feel like we've just
moved beyond it
um but i could if we if we end up having
time this week
bw rock says did i see a sandwich shop
owner from west virginia was arrested in
the sicknick murder your thoughts on the
well-off storming their own capital
i did see that i did see that um i'm
probably going to cover that tomorrow
it broke today when i was preparing for
the show so i did not get an
opportunity to look at it in detail but
i absolutely am going to be uh
going to be looking at that you can
check the status
of your stimulus on the irs website i'm
getting mine on wednesday
very good thank you mario for people
looking to do that
i want to say thank you to harmony davis
for signing up at joinpakman.com
also want to say thanks to excuse me
choking here matthew peterson using the
coupon code
immoral 21 and storm bastin also using
the coupon code immoral 21 that puts us
at 25.
whoa actually hold on
we're getting some pretty pretty big
membership dumps juan salazar just
signed up with the code immoral21
taylor neil signed up with the coupon
code immoral21 appreciate that
yeah a lot of interest in that coupon
code and it is not illegal it is immoral
but not illegal
david did you see majority report has 13
emotes they've only had a sub for a week
are we getting more emotes
i have no idea as far as i knew i'm
using
all the emotes that i can if someone can
actually email me and let me know
like i thought you could do five emotes
and then a couple more
for tier two and then a couple more for
tier three
i i can't manage this while streaming
but if someone wants to email me and
tell me exactly how to add more emotes
i will gladly do it i am not holding
back emotes
just for punishment big thank you to
anthony knight using the coupon code
immoral 21
leonard gastler has used the coupon code
immoral 21.
dan olays and randall hoyle have used
the code
will moore and evan shalecross
using the coupon code immoral 21 luke
winters
and chris arroyo using the coupon code
immoral 21
quinn catherine tucker as well as kurt
snyder
using the coupon code that's 10.
a lot of interest a lot of interest in
the coupon code
david what are your thoughts on matthew
mcconaughey possibly running for texas
governor so my thoughts are mixed
on the one hand i like the idea in some
abstract sense on the other hand i don't
know if the direction we should be going
in
is just more celebrities running for
political office because if you replace
like lawyers and career politicians with
actors
are we really better off if we're still
keeping
scientists out if we're keeping teachers
out
if we're keeping you know that that's
kind of my
my concern about it um i i
you know there's rumors now that megan
megan varkell who's of course married
to prince william uh is maybe looking at
running for president and
all of these different things i'm just
not sure i'm just not sure
um who you got in the meltwater magnus
chess tournament i don't know probably
hikaru
what's an emote emotes are graphical
elements on twitch
graphical elements on twitch i want to
say thanks to heidi stanley for signing
up with the coupon code immoral21
firecrafted has also signed up with a
moral 21 it's a secret coupon code
also thanks to valerie woodfak for using
the coupon code
gregory meeks is a new member with the
code
marcus perez and matthew levislee
have used the code immoral 21. jennifer
spencer
as well as stuart mitchell have signed
up with a coupon code i'm having trouble
keeping up actually
and elizabeth whitmore has also signed
up that's nine
plus 9 9 plus 7 is 16 carry the 1
puts us at 46 if my math is right
the coupon code only works on my website
i see people on twitch saying the coupon
code
isn't working it's only on my website
guys
only on my website thanks to quasar
chuck makes it oh wait chuck makes it i
already think
just quasar thanks for the twitch sub
did i watch john oliver's piece on
tucker carlson i did not
braelyn's dad says david do you do you
what nfts are i know what they are
non-fungible tokens
you would and do you think they are the
future do you own any so
i'm gonna try to explain what i believe
non-fungible tokens are and then
chat will tell me if i'm describing this
correctly
imagine something like a uh
very expensive work of art worth five
million dollars
okay which has you know it has one owner
it could be owned in like an llc or
something where
maybe there are five owners okay you
start with like a really five million
dollar piece of art
if i want to invest in that piece of art
but i don't have the 5 million to buy it
nor do i want to worry about
storing the piece of art if you tokenize
the piece of art and say the 5 million
we're going to offer it
as five million one dollar tokens
and i can say great i want to invest
five grand
i'm going to buy 5 000 tokens
in this piece of art and then if the
value of the piece of art goes from five
million to ten million
my five thousand dollars in tokens is
now worth ten thousand dollars in tokens
and then now i can sell my tokens i
never owned the painting i didn't have
to worry about storage shipping
insurance
but now i've been able to invest in this
piece of art
is this right is this at all am i
describing it at all correctly
you can do that with nfts but it's not
what they
are
fractional shares a lot of people saying
they have no idea
okay if someone can send me a simple
guide to nfts via email
i will read it and be more informed next
time i don't own
any nfts um
okay here's joe biden let's take a look
good afternoon
when i signed the american rescue plan
last week i said help is on the way
this week on every i can report isn't
just on the way it's here
beautiful sooner than many ever thought
possible over the next 10 days we will
reach
two goals two giant goals the first is
100 million shots in people's arms
will have been completed within the next
10 days and 100 million
checks in people's pockets in the next
hundred days
shots and arms and money in pockets
that's important the american rescue
plan is already doing
what it was designed to do make a
difference in people's everyday
lives we're just getting started by the
time all the money is distributed
85 percent of american households will
have gotten a one thousand four hundred
dollar
rescue checks to give more to give one
more example
for the average family of two parents
and two children
making a combined income of 110 thousand
dollars a year
that's going to add five thousand six
hundred dollars
for them five thousand six hundred
dollars they'll get
and the plan does a lot more it extends
unemployment insurance for the 11
million americans unemployed than any
who will be unemployed
in the near term it will help hundreds
of thousands of small businesses keep
their doors open
which makes a gigantic difference in
neighborhoods and communities
if you have a drugstore if you have a a
beauty shop
a hardware store it's a center of small
communities
and it gets our schools and resources
they need to open safely
it provides the biggest investment in
child care since world war
ii and it provides food and nutrition
help
for the millions of families keep them
from going hungry keeping a roof over
their heads
and it expands health care coverage and
lowers healthcare
costs for so many people and it will cut
child poverty in half in this country
that's the estimate child poverty will
be cut in half as a consequence of
what's in this recovery act and it will
generate
economic growth for the entire nation
that's why
major economists left right and center
support this plan
even wall street has agreed according to
moody's
by the end of this year this law will
spur our economy to create
seven million new jobs
and does one more thing it focuses on
rebuilding the backbone of this country
working families the middle class
people who built this country but as i
said last week
it's one thing to pass a historic piece
of legislation like the american rescue
plan
and it's quite another to implement it
right and the devil
is in the details anyone can just
announce vaccines the point is
getting people vaccinated arrives
quickly equitably and efficiently with
no waste or fraud
in your bank account in your mailbox to
the local business
in your community and to your child's
school
look i've been here before when
president obama and i came to office in
2009
he put me in charge of implementing the
recovery act
which helped us recover and rebuild
during the great recession
i was authorized to put together a team
including an accountability board with
inspectors general
from different agencies that were
affected by the act to make sure we got
the roughly 800 billion dollars out out
of the countryside by the book and
quickly over 18 months i talked to
literally
almost over 150 mayors
all governors except one constantly
going over the granular detail
of the implementation of this
legislation that legislation
and the effort put us on a path from
crisis
to recovery to resurgence accordingly
to the oversight board that is of
inspectors general
they said we got it done with less than
two tenths
of one percent waste or fraud
and that's not what the previous
administration did though
when the congress last year passed the
cares act
the care is that the congress created a
committee
of inspectors general to make sure every
penny of that money was spent as it was
directed
wasn't it disbanded one of the first
things that the administration
did was fire right the head of the
inspector general's committee
right so when congress passed what was
intended to be a small business relief
program
it instead became a free-for-all for
well-connected companies
and mainstream mainstream businesses
from hardware stores to beauty salons
that needed to help most were left
behind
400 000 are now gone we will not
let that happen this time i learned from
my experience
implementing the recovery act just how
important it is to have someone
who can manage all the moving parts with
efficiency
speed and integrity and accountability
that's the sort of management we've seen
in our fight against the virus
with jeff science our covert response
coordinator
and today i'm pleased to announce
and introduce another gifted manager to
coordinate our implementation
of the american rescue plan gene
sperling
gene will be on the phone with mayors
and governors that'll be interesting
the source of constant communication a
source of guidance and support
and above all a source of accountability
for all of us to get the job done gene's
been here before
the only person in history to serve as
director of economic of the national
economic council
twice he led successful efforts
to deliver relief to small businesses
and unemployed americans
in the obama biden administration and in
the clinton administration
i spoke with gene earlier today
alongside my economic team
he's ready to get to work in fact he's
already hit the ground running
and together we're going to make sure
that the benefits of the american rescue
plan
go out quickly and directly to the
american people
where they belong let me close with this
help is here and hope is here
in real and tangible ways we're just
days away from 100 million shots
and millions in the arms of millions of
americans
that's the way that's the way on the way
to get every single american access to
the vaccine
100 million checks going into the
pockets and or direct deposits going
into the pockets of americans
on the way to a million more millions of
more americans
that's real progress we have a lot more
to do
we have to prove to the american people
that their government can't deliver for
them
and do it without waste or fraud
that we can vaccinate the nation that we
can get our kids safely back in school
that we can get our economy back on
track by helping hundreds of thousands
of small businesses open and stay open
and that we can give people this nation
a fighting chance again
with relief checks lower child care
costs
lower health care costs and so much more
that's our job that's our responsibility
and the process will be growing the
economy as well
we're going to have to stay on top of
every dollar spent through the american
rescue plan
and that's what we're going to do we can
do this
we will do this god bless you all
help us on the way and may god protect
our troops
thank you very very much gene
sperling came to hold on
i'm hearing a lot of reports from
serious reporters like you saying that
i discussed it with my team and they say
the thing that has
more impact than anything trump would
say to the
maggie folks is what the local doctor
what the local preachers what the local
people in the community say
so i urge i urge all local docs and
and ministers and priests and to talk
about
why why it's important to get it
to get that vaccine and even after that
until everyone
is in fact vaccinated to wear this mask
yeah all right so there is joe biden
announcing the money is going out and
it's going to be continuing to go out
and
that is all happening so another um
statement from joe biden we are
expecting now
you know in the midst of what's going on
um
coveted stimulus uh we've got
a pandemic still going on we have you
know all these different things
vaccination for some people the main
problem in america right now is that
it's been 54 days and joe biden hasn't
done a press briefing yet
a lot of people are very angry about
that uh i guess he's going to do one
soon and when he does
i'm i'm going to be covering it okay let
me get to some oh hold on there's people
people taking advantage of the coupon
code immoral 21 and i'm gonna get to the
super chats in a moment i want to say
thanks to
micah rondeau
patricia collins
gloria yang jonathan gamboa
thanks to marcos lopez and abe garcia
thank you to nick thorburn and melana
grassy
thanks to pascal archambault and ryan
herzer
big thank you to rhonda potter as well
as jan olson
or jan robert peterson
and amanda masis muskiki hold on
miss kiki i think i'm saying that right
devin standphil
and marie aquendo
christopher reed and martin kirov
as well as natalie anderson that's 19
putting us at 67.
and i appreciate that also thanks to
shokomania query m
and uh for signing up via twitch
putting us at 69. the the new coupon
code it's a secret coupon code it's
immoral 21.
okay mallory says biden needs to start
taking press questions this is getting
ridiculous
i i would be glad for him to note that
some days he's saying it uh
he's taking press questions sometimes
twice in a day he's just not
done a formal press briefing and i would
love for him to do it
people are saying i have the wrong
coupon code up immoral 21 is a
it's an unpublished coupon that we
created during the stream that's why
it's not up there you have to be in the
know
all right thank you um mr crypto says
any shot of adult dependence ever
getting any help my mom claimed me on
her taxes before the pandemic even
though i live alone
and i still get nothing so i know i know
uh elderly dependents
and college a i don't know i have no
idea to be honest mr crypto
i don't know enough about that david
what's your opinion regarding bills
discussed this month regarding puerto
rican statehood or
self self-determination i've not
followed the bills
politically and because i believe they
deserve representation as american
citizens i like the idea of puerto rico
as a state but ultimately they should
want to be a state
i i'm not up to speed on what happened
over the next last few days i sort of
tuned out for the weekend
is there no fear of inflation the amount
of money in circulation must have
increased
immensely what are your thoughts david
well number one they've been doing the
inflation fear-mongering for 40 years
and the u.s has had some of the most
controlled inflation
of the world for decades so it's not
happening number one and number two
once you start understanding modern
monetary theory and the idea that the
government can deficit spend
on stimulative things or unstimulative
things
and that is what determines whether you
will have a so-called inflation spiral
or not okay
stuart mitchell says just resigned but
felt it was immoral to use the discount
code love your show david thank you
kade smith says how much of my 199 super
chat this youtube get you know i'm not
sure i'm allowed to say
we get most of it but i don't know that
i'm allowed to say i don't want to
violate
um my youtube agreement
jd says some people are saying that whap
is the female ghostbusters
compared to the yin yang twins and the
original ghostbusters couldn't tell you
no idea francisco says david my wife and
i love your show can you give a shout
out to vanessa
yes vanessa thank you appreciate it
hope you and paco are doing well
okay and i think otherwise i'm caught up
good also want to say thanks to sarah
baker for signing up on my website
aubry for signing up on my website
case done for signing up and karen
mclellan
all for signing up at joinpackman.com
um i see a lot of people asking when is
joe biden doing his
joint address to the house and senate
it's a state of the union without being
a state of the union typically in their
first year
new presidents they do the address but
they don't call it the state of the
union
i don't know we are on we are here this
week and next week and then we're on
spring break
don't worry i'm not going to south beach
to go completely bonkers at a club with
no mask
that's not what i'm doing we're calling
it spring break but it's going to be
very very safe beach going is what i
have ahead of me
um i hope that it's before then because
i'd like to cover it we were told it
would be in march
uh we leave on march 26th which leaves
like unless it's gonna be the 31st it
should be either this week or next week
i i want to cover it i don't yet have a
schedule
a date i don't have a date at this point
okay um
now people are saying april i didn't see
that let's see biden
joint address congress april
okay march 5th biden addressed the
congress could be pushed back for covid
relief promotion
um oh potentially pushing his first
address as late as
april that would be horrible i'm not
loving that i mean listen i'll cover it
whenever unless it's during our week off
but a lot of that week off is two
weekends so the odds are like low-ish
but uh
yeah we'll we'll just have to see then
we'll just have to see
all right guys appreciate everybody who
joined me
we are not really caring about this
completely xenophobic uh fiasco
at the border with kevin mccarthy and
other republicans
so that's gonna do it for me and we're
gonna be back very soon
probably will cover the press briefing
tomorrow alright so i'll see everybody
then